Hi, everybody. Ashley here. Today our topic is going to be on the PAN-1 gene. So many
of us haven't really heard of that before. So let me tell you about it. What is the PAN-1
gene? So this is going to be one of our detox genes. It is actually a really important gene
involved with the detoxification process. It is how we detox our pesticides, herbicides, vaccines,
medications, really large chemicals. So we want to make sure that we know if we have it or not
because it is so important. We want to rethink the use of toxic household cleaners,
long-cares sprays, flu shot vaccines, deep bug spray, toxic beauty products. We even want to try to
eat organic. If you have defects in this gene, these are reasons why you would want to know
because constant exposure over time can likely develop in disease. So this is going to be a
really important something that you want to know for detoxification. Also new research is starting
to come out that vaping can even contain pesticides. So now that's a new form of getting pesticides in
your system outside of just food and water, it's now something that people are inhaling.
So this is an example of what a genetic report looks like with our pond 1 gene specifically.
So I actually put together a family here. So the top two are the dad and the mom. And then we have
the two children underneath here. So you can see that between the mom and dad, that the children do
get the pond 1 passed down. So your genes, they all look very similar. But this is an important piece,
especially if parents are vaccinating their children. The important piece for this would be to maybe
wait till they're at least of age 3. So then their blood brain barrier is developed. Otherwise,
not vaccinating your kids at all would also be something to consider due to how the defects and the
pond 1 can really impact somebody. So what can you do if you have defects in your pond 1? You could
take a pond 1 assist support supplement or a homeopathic spray support supplement. Otherwise,
just making sure you're really supporting your detox organ. So doing a liver cleanse is great,
detox therapies such as like sweating things out. So exercise of course is great all around for
all of your genes. So it doesn't hurt you to do that. But other detox therapies of course can
definitely help. You can find these two products on shop.conorsclinic.com for more information on each
of them. And then you can also check out our website regarding a genetic report as well. So you can see
if you have any pond 1 defects if it's something you're going to pass down to your kids, those types of
things. And also just to live a healthier lifestyle in general and adjust to your genes. So creating
clean genes. If you have any other questions, feel free to contact our clinic. Otherwise, check out
our website.conorsclinic.com. Thank you.